Charles, can you figure this out?
>> Yes, I believe I can. So, the first thing to note is that because we're
sticking with just 0 and 1, and not
all possible values in between, we're thinking about
a binary function. And the output is also
binary. Which makes me think of Boolean functions,
where zero represents false and one represents true,
which is a common trick in machine learning.
>> Alright, so and let me,
let me mark those on the picture here. So
we're talking about the only four combinations are here. And
you're saying in particular. That we're interpreting
these as combinations of true and false.
>> Right
>> False, false true false, false true and true, true.
>> Exactly and if you look at it the only way that you get
something above the line is when both are true. And that is called and.
>> Also take conjunction. Right, exactly so,
exactly so. So this is, even though
we're, you know we're setting these numerical values but it actually
is, gives us a way of specifying a kind of logic key.
>> Right. So here's a question for you Michael. Could we do or?
>> That's a very good question. Or looks a lot like And in this space, it,
it seems like it aught to be possible. So let's let's do that as a quiz. .